how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel all things mcu
and of course that means we are talking
a lot about
spider-man 3. spider-man 3 and wanda
vision have pretty much been all of the
hype that we've had this year
but things are about to ramp up as
marvel has unveiled their entire phase 4
slate and a little bit of phase 5 as
well
but all eyes are on spider-man 3 right
now as sony has promised a first
look at spider-man 3 in december by the
end of the year
and it appears like we have an official
confirmation of the spider-verse and an
official release date for
either the teaser trailer or whatever it
is that they're going to give us
they honestly don't even have to show us
a teaser trailer they could just simply
show us a photo of three spider-man
together and the whole entire internet
would break
but let's hope we get as much as we
possibly can on the date that they are
going to release this teaser which we
now
seemingly know and the date that sony is
planning on giving us this teaser
as a gift is reportedly christmas day
december
25th this was revealed by the official
paramount pictures spanish network
account
a couple of days ago they sent out this
tweet that seemingly confirms the
release date of the teaser
and confirms the spider-verse for toby
maguire andrew garfield and of course
tom holland their tweet said this marvel
gives you a christmas gift it is a box
that if you open it all three spider-man
of the 21st century appear
in the same film it then shows a picture
in the tweet of tobey maguire and
andrew garfield with the words over it
that translate to
toby maguire and andrew garfield will
return again as peter parker
spider-man 3 will explore the spider
multiverse
this is an official account for
paramount pictures an official source
is confirming that toby maguire and
andrew garfield are going to be
returning for spider-man 3. they're also
saying that we're going to get our first
teaser or gift on christmas day on
december 25th
so it seems like we know the official
date for our teaser trailer
and now at this point in time everybody
except for marvel
and sony have basically confirmed the
spider-verse and spider-man 3.
it's been reported by numerous different
trade sources sources that have been
right many times in the past
and now official sources for very huge
film companies
so this is pretty much an official
confirmation there's no reason for this
company to tweet this out unless it is
100
absolutely true they literally have
nothing to gain from tweeting that out
unless it's true
now as far as the teaser actually goes
we may actually get to see toby mcguire
and andrew garfield in the teaser
this tweet says we get the gift of all
three spider-man of the 21st century in
one film
that means that the spider-verse is
going to be revealed in this gift or
the teaser that we're going to be
getting and if they're going to reveal
the spider-verse that means we should
see
toby mcguire and andrew garfield if not
them personally
than someone in a spider-man suit three
spider-man together
it could be stand-ins stunt doubles or
cgi or like i said they could simply
show the three of them together and
break the internet
either way i am super excited to see
what we're going to get on december 25th
if
this ends up being true which again it
comes from an official verified account
so it seems 100
legitimate let me know what you would
like to see as far as a teaser is
concerned on christmas day
let me know in the comments down below
and don't forget to subscribe so you can
enter this week's giveaway for a chance
to win a modok
funko pop from the marvel avengers game
i'll be picking a winner on friday for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much
for watching woof
you